peu après la hausse élevée des prix mondiaux de la nourriture en 2008.
Les gens souffraient et luttaient,
les dirigeants mondiaux
devaient nous prouver qu'ils étaient attentifs
et qu'ils tentaient de le régler.
2050 est si loin dans le futur
qu'on ne peut pas l'imaginer,
et surtout,
si on ne change pas,
ça va nous arriver beaucoup plus tôt.
Je pense qu'on doit se demander autre chose.
La réponse à cette question
doit être formulée autrement.
Si on peut reformuler l'ancien discours
et le remplacer par de nouveaux chiffres
qui offrent une vision plus globale,
des chiffres que tout le monde comprend
et assimile,
on peut éviter la crise.
J'ai été courtière en marchandises
et j'ai appris une chose en commerçant,
c'est que chaque marché a un point de bascule,
quand le changement arrive si vite
qu'il affecte le monde
et les choses changent pour toujours.
Prenez la dernière crise financière
ou la bulle Internet.
Voilà ce qui m'inquiète.
On pourrait avoir un point de bascule
dans l'alimentation mondiale et l'agriculture
si la forte demande
surpasse la capacité du système agricole à produire de la nourriture.
L'offre ne peut plus suivre la demande
malgré la flambée des prix,
sauf si on change les structures.
Cette fois-là,
il ne s'agit pas de bourses et d'argent.
Il s'agit de personnes.
Elles pourraient mourir et les gouvernements s'effondrer.
Savoir à quel moment l'offre a du mal
à suivre la demande en hausse
était simplement un intérêt quand je commerçais
et est devenu une véritable obsession.
C'est devenu une obsession
quand j'ai compris, à travers mes recherches, les problèmes du système
et comment peu d'informations servaient à prendre des décisions importantes.
C'est à ce moment-là que j'ai décidé de quitter Wall Street
et de me lancer dans l’entrepreneuriat
en créant Gro Intelligence.
À Gro, notre but est de prendre ces données
et de tout faire pour qu'elles soient reconnues,
pour valoriser les décisionnaires à tous les niveaux.
En faisant cela,
on a réalisé que le monde,
pas juste les chefs d'État,
mais aussi les sociétés et les citoyens comme chacun d'entre nous,
avaient besoin d'un guide concret
sur la façon d'éviter une future crise alimentaire mondiale.
Alors on a créé un modèle,
en exploitant les pétaoctets de données que nous avons
et on a résolu le point de bascule.
Personne ne sait que l'on travaille sur ce problème
et c'est la première fois que je partage nos découvertes.
On a découvert que le point de bascule sera dans 10 ans.
On a découvert que le monde
aura perdu 214 trillions de calories
d'ici 2027.
Le monde ne peut pas combler ce manque.
Vous remarquerez
que ma formulation est différente de celle que j'avais au début
et c'est intentionnel car jusqu'à présent,
ce problème a été quantifié grâce à la masse :
pensez kilogrammes, tonnes, hectogrammes,
une unité de référence en masse.
Pourquoi parle-t-on de nourriture en termes de poids ?
Parce que c'est facile.
On peut regarder une photo et déterminer le tonnage sur un bateau
en utilisant une simple calculatrice de poche.
On peut peser des camions, des avions et des charrettes.
Mais ce qui importe, c'est la valeur nutritionnelle de la nourriture.
Tous les aliments ne sont pas égaux,
même s'ils font le même poids.
Je l'ai appris personnellement
quand j'ai quitté l'Éthiopie pour étudier aux USA.
Quand je suis rentrée,
mon père, très heureux de me voir,
m'a accueilli en me demandant pourquoi j'étais grosse.
Il se trouve que manger
à peu près la même quantité de nourriture en Amérique, qu'en Ethiopie,
avait quelque peu accentué mes formes.
C'est pourquoi on doit s'intéresser aux calories,
pas à la masse.
Ce sont les calories qui nous nourrissent.
214 trillions de calories est un très grand nombre,
et pas même les plus dévoués d'entre nous
ne pensent en centaines de trillions de calories.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer autrement.
Une façon différente d'y penser
est d'y penser en Big Macs.
214 trillions de calories.
Un seul Big Mac a 563 calories.
Ce qui veut dire que le monde aura perdu 379 milliards de Big Macs en 2027.
C'est plus de Big Macs que McDonald's ait jamais produits.
Comment a-t-on fait pour trouver ces chiffres ?
Ils ne sont pas inventés.
Cette carte vous montre le monde il y a 40 ans.
Elle montre les écarts nets de calories dans chaque pays du monde.
En clair,
ce sont les calories consommées dans un pays
moins les calories produites dans le même pays.
Ce n'est pas une déclaration sur la malnutrition.
Cela montre juste combien de calories sont consommées par an
moins combien sont produites.
Les pays en bleu sont les exportateurs nets de calories,
ou auto-suffisants.
Ils ont des réserves pour les mauvais jours.
Les pays en rouge sont les importateurs nets de calories.
Plus le rouge est foncé,
plus ils importent.
Il y a 40 ans, tellement peu de pays étaient exportateurs nets de calories,
que je pouvais les énumerer.
Un grande partie du continent africain,
de l'Europe, la majorité de l'Asie,
de l'Amérique du Sud sauf l'Argentine,
étaient des importateurs nets de calories.
Étonnamment, la Chine était auto-suffisante sur le plan alimentaire.
L'Inde était un gros importateur net de calories.
40 ans après, nous voilà.
Vous voyez la transformation drastique qui s'est produite dans le monde.
Le Brésil est devenu une puissance agricole.
L'Europe domine l'agriculture mondiale.
L'Inde est même passée du rouge au bleu.
Elle est devenue auto-suffisante en nourriture.
Et la Chine est passée du bleu clair
au rouge vif que vous voyez sur la carte.
Comment a-t-on atteint ce résultat ? Que s'est-il passé ?
Ce graphique montre l'Inde et l'Afrique.
La ligne bleue est l'Inde, et la rouge, l'Afrique.
Comment deux régions ayant commencé de la même façon
dans des trajectoires similaires
prennent des chemins si différents ?
L'Inde a connu une révolution verte.
Aucun pays africain n'a connu de révolution verte.
Le résultat net ?
L'Inde est auto-suffisante
et a exporté des calories ces dix dernières années.
Le continent africain importe aujourd'hui 300 trillions de calories par an.
Ajoutons la Chine, la ligne verte.
Vous vous souvenez du passage du bleu au rouge vif ?
Que s'est-il passé et quand ?
La Chine semblait prendre le même chemin que l'Inde
jusqu'au début du 21ème siècle,
quand elle a changé de direction.
Une population jeune et croissante
combinée à une croissance économique importante
s'est imposée en force
et aucun marché ne l'a vu venir.
Ce changement de direction était important pour les marchés agricoles mondiaux.
Heureusement, l'Amérique du Sud
commençait à prospérer en même temps que la Chine,
alors l'offre et la demande étaient toujours équilibrées.
Alors la question est :
« Que fait-on maintenant ? »
Bizarrement,
ce n'est pas nouveau,
sauf que cette fois ce n'est pas juste l'histoire de la Chine.
C'est sa continuation,
une amplification de l'Afrique
et un changement radical en Inde.
D'ici 2023,
on prévoit que la population africaine dépassera celle de l'Inde et de la Chine.
D'ici 2023, ces trois régions
représenteront ensemble la moitié de la population mondiale.
Ce point de croisement présente des défis intéressants concernant
la sécurité alimentaire mondiale.
Et quelques années plus tard, on est impacté par cette réalité.
À quoi ressemblera le monde dans dix ans ?
Jusqu'ici, l'Inde est autosuffisante sur le plan alimentaire.
La plupart des prévisionnistes prévoit qu'elle le restera.
Pas nous.
L'Inde deviendra bientôt un importateur net de calories.
Et ce grâce à deux choses :
la demande grandissante du point de vue de la croissance démographique
et économique.
Ce sont les deux raisons.
Même si vous êtes optimistes
à propos de la croissance de la production,
il y aura un léger changement.
Ce changement peut avoir des implications importantes.
Puis l'Afrique restera importateur net de calories,
toujours grâce à la croissance démographique et économique.
Toujours selon les prédictions optimistes sur la croissance de production.
Puis en Chine,
où la population diminue,
la consommation de calories explosera
car les types de calories consommées
deviendront aussi des aliments à forte teneur en calories.
Par conséquent,
ces trois régions combinées
présentent un défi intéressant pour le monde.
Jusqu'à présent, les pays avec un déficit en calories
ont réussi à surmonter ces déficits
avec l'aide de régions excédentaires.
Par régions excédentaires, j’entends
l'Amérique du Nord, l'Amérique du Sud et l'Europe.
Ce diagramme vous montre
la croissance et la croissance prévue pour la prochaine décennie de production
en Amérique du Nord, du Sud et en Europe.
Ce qu'il ne vous montre pas,
c'est qu'une grande partie vient d'Amérique du Sud.
Et une grande partie
se fera au prix de la déforestation.
Quand vous regardez la hausse de la demande combinée
venant d'Inde, de Chine et d'Afrique,
et que vous la comparez à celle de la production combinée
venant d'Inde, de Chine, d'Afrique,
d'Amérique du Nord, du Sud et d'Europe,
vous vous retrouvez avec un déficit de 214 trillions de calories
que l'on ne peut pas produire.
Ce qui suppose qu'on prenne tout le surplus de calories
produites en Amérique du Nord, du Sud et en Europe
pour les exporter seulement en Inde, en Chine et en Afrique.
Ce que je vous ai présenté est la vision d'un monde impossible.
On peut changer ça.
Changer nos habitudes de consommation,
réduire la gaspillage
ou s'engager fermement
à augmenter rapidement les rendements.
Je ne vais pas discuter
des habitudes de consommation ou du gaspillage
car on en on parle déjà depuis quelque temps.
Rien n'a changé.
Rien n'a changé car ces débats
impliquent que les excédentaires changent de comportement
pour les déficitaires.
Attendre que les autres changent de comportement
pour vous, votre survie,
est une mauvaise idée.
C'est contre-productif.
Je veux proposer une alternative venant des régions en rouge.
La Chine, l'Inde, l'Afrique.
La Chine est limitée concernant la quantité de terres
disponibles pour l'agriculture
et a des problèmes de disponibilité de ressources hydriques.
La réponse vient de l'Inde et de l'Afrique.
L'inde est avantagée en termes de hausses potentielles de rendements.
C'est l'écart entre son rendement actuel
et le rendement maximal qu'elle peut théoriquement atteindre.
Il reste des terres cultivables, mais très peu.
L'Inde est limitée en terres.
D'un autre côté, l'Afrique
dispose de beaucoup de terres cultivables
et d'un important potentiel de hausse des rendements.
C'est un peu simplifié mais,
si vous regardez les rendements actuels en maïs de l'Afrique subsaharienne,
ils sont là où ceux de l'Amérique du Nord étaient en 1940.
On n'a pas 70 ans pour résoudre ceci,
alors il va falloir essayer quelque chose de nouveau
et de différent.
La solution commence par les réformes.
On doit réformer et commercialiser
les industries agricoles en Afrique
et en Inde.
La commercialisation
n'est pas simplement l'agriculture commerciale.
Il s'agit de recueillir des informations
pour définir de meilleures politiques,
pour améliorer l'infrastructure,
pour réduire les coûts de transport
et pour réformer entièrement les secteurs financiers et les assurances.
La commercialisation, c'est faire passer l’agriculture
d'une entreprise trop risquée à une entreprise porteuse d'avenir.
Il ne s'agit pas que des agriculteurs.
Il s'agit de tout le système agricole.
Mais la commercialisation signifie aussi faire face au fait que
l'on ne peut plus faire porter le poids de la croissance
aux seuls petits agriculteurs
et accepter que les fermes commerciales et l'introduction de celles-ci
puissen produire des économies d'échelle
exploitables par les petits agriculteurs.
Il ne s'agit pas de la petite agriculture
par opposition à l'agriculture à grande échelle.
On peut créer les premiers modèles réussis de la coexistence et du succès
de la petite agriculture aux côtés de l'agriculture commerciale.
Car pour la première fois,
l'outil essentiel pour réussir dans l'industrie,
l'information,
devient moins cher chaque jour.
Et bientôt, peu importera la richesse
ou l'importance de quelqu'un
pour prendre les bonnes décisions et maximiser les possibilités de succès
pour atteindre l'objectif prévu.
Les sociétés comme Gro travaillent dur pour rendre cela possible.
Si on se tient à cette initiative nouvelle et audacieuse,
à ce changement nouveau et audacieux,
on peut non seulement résoudre le déficit de 214 trillions de calories
mais aussi mettre le monde sur un nouveau chemin.
L'Inde peut rester auto-suffisante en nourriture
et l'Afrique peut devenir la prochaine région bleu foncé du monde.
La nouvelle question est :
« Comment produire 214 trillions de calories
pour nourrir 8,3 milliards de personnes d'ici 2027 ? »
On a la solution.
On doit juste passer à l'action.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)